we live in a world of big data and
people talk about big data all the time
but until data is actually sorted in a
way that makes sense and truly open so
that people can have access to it the
fact that we're surrounded by data
doesn't change much hi my name is Todd
crane and I'm here for a reason TV and I
am here with Chris gates of the sunlight
foundation which is an organization that
is dedicated to increasing transparency
in government and politics out what is
the sunlight foundation all about so the
sunlight foundation was founded actually
almost exactly nine years ago our ninth
birthday is just coming up by my client
and Ellen Miller with a real focus on
Congress originally and it was about
bringing more transparency and
accountability to Congress and and I'm
just curious how does it break down in
term or does it break down in terms of
the kinds of politicians who may support
more transparency initiatives versus
those who are a little weary of it it
honestly doesn't if you look at the you
know there are a few people who carry
bills to try and make things happen but
invariably they struggle to get
co-sponsors from either side and it's
just generally there's not a huge
constituency on either side of the
island washington for this work which is
why the work is so hard when people tell
me that it must be tough to work in
Washington where no one can agree on
anything I remind them all that they're
incredibly naive and they don't
understand how the world works because
in fact there's one issue that where
there's clear bipartisan agreement in
this town and that is that too much
transparency and accountability are
probably a really bad thing and both
parties seem to agree on that one and
how about the you mentioned Congress but
what about the executive branch of the
president and the president's kummel
under a lot of scrutiny he certainly
came into office promising to be the
most transparent administration in
history and I'm curious what how you
score him in that regard has had what
has he done right what does President
Obama done wrong you know I'll lead the
the grading and the scores to historians
but from our perspective there are some
things that have gone well and some
things that haven't gone well and some
some real challenges one issue was that
in early 2013 he issued an executive
order and asked every federal agency and
Department
to develop in essence lists of all the
data sets that they held and they did
that and we applauded it was a great
thing because you can't if you're
Congress you can't provide oversight
over data that you don't know whether it
exists and if you're an activist you
can't FOIA something if you don't know
whether or not it exists and so it was a
great thing that he said let's have
every agency developed the list of their
data inventories they did that and then
they went to OMB and I'm gonna be
declined to release them so it was good
that he asked for them then they didn't
release them then we foiled them in
almost a year and a half later just a
few months ago they finally released
them which we thought was good so we're
back to good and then we actually just
wrote about this today that there i
think five departments that have still
declined to put the lists of their data
inventories on the date or gov website
so it's so it's it's it's like cycles
it's good and bad okay and we and when
you say datasets in general what does
that refer to so literally until the
president issued this executive order in
2013 departments themselves didn't fully
know what data they collected and what
data they had now that they've been
released we've discovered things that we
didn't know existed and the Congress
didn't know existed and you know for
instance the Bureau of Land Management
actually has a data set of complaints
about unsafe conditions in mines that
folks didn't know about and if you live
in a state like West Virginia that's
probably a pretty important topic and a
piece of data that you'd like to see but
it's a piece of data that we didn't know
existed until this this was released I
was just reading about that in fact
they're like something there are tens of
thousands of these mines that are spread
out over federal labs right and so you
know it's interesting we we live in a
world of a big data and people talk
about big data all the time but until
data is actually sorted in a way that
makes sense and truly open so the people
can have access to it the fact that
we're surrounded by data doesn't change
much it's really what you do with it and
so in this case it's about understanding
it and understanding what's there and
then ensuring that it can be public and
it can be released you so you've had
success with FOIA and that's really good
to hear but my understanding at least
from my point of view as a journal
is that Freedom of Information Act have
been harder and harder to come by
because they've been easier easier to
deny their sore all sorts of loopholes
that allow the government to restrict
access and Freedom of Information
requests is that been getting better
over time as I've been getting worse
over time what's the story with the
rejection I'm not sure that you can have
an overarching conclusion about FOIA
requests because they happen for some
are very political some are not some our
efforts at gotcha some are fishing
expeditions and so I'm not sure that you
can generalize I think that that
certainly in our experience what we
discovered was that we were never turned
down but it was simply the can kept
being kicked down the road and and
frankly I'm not sure if we hadn't moved
forward with the threat of a lawsuit if
we would have had the data released the
Department of Health and Human Services
just announced I think a week ago that
because of the difficulty of
administering Obamacare they wanted to
let people know that it was going to be
difficult for them to respond to FOIA
requests because of staff limitations
that seems sort of like an odd evasion
around that because of Obamacare that
FOIA requests would be slower to be
responded to and so there I think there
again they're good instances and bad
instances there are certainly folks that
that probably abuse the system and and
and make sort of too many claims and
political claims but in general I think
it is is really important that there be
a clear system that allows people
whether it's congress for oversight
whether it's journalists whether its
citizens to ask for this information and
get this information and unless there
are clear and specific reasons why that
information shouldn't be available the
default setting has to be on open and
i'm curious also about if you if the
sunlight foundation deals at all with
sort of the unprecedented crackdown
we've had on leakers whether it's
Chelsea Manning or Edward Snowden or
James rise and we've seen people
prosecuted under the Espionage Act in
this administration to historic degrees
and I'm curious if that's a concern of
the sunlight foundation and what can be
done about that from your point of view
like traditionally we've been very
supportive of whistleblower protection
and think that that it's really
important that people not be prosecuted
or persecuted for for sharing
information that is you know damaging to
their employer damaging to their
organization the place where we have not
really entered the conversation is
around national security which is I
think a very different conversation as
it relates to Snowden or Assange or any
of those sets of issues Bradley Manning
that our focus has been more around the
traditional not national
security-related whistleblower and we've
been very supportive of whistleblower
protection and critical of of efforts
when that protection hasn't been there I
want to talk about some of one of the
more interesting developments that the
sunlight foundation to this politics you
have my pronouncing that correctly is
enough close enough yeah apollo's so
okay so okay so explain what it I think
it's very cool explain what it is and
how does it work so we follow the
twitter accounts of every member of
Congress and a lot of elected officials
around the country and so we are able to
tell if somebody post something and then
deletes it you know we're not saying
that people delete tweets because
they're terrible people because a lot of
times you just post the wrong thing but
invariably there are great back stories
that people post pictures of themselves
at events and they later think probably
not the smartest thing for me to have
been at that event or been with that
person and so it gets deleted the beau
Bergdahl case was a great one where
initially when he was released there are
many elected officials who were tweeting
congratulations welcome home you know
American hero because that was the
original narrative right before we heard
more and then there was this need which
is curious to go back later and expunge
the record and start deleting their
tweets and so it's it's it's a fun
window into the the world of framing and
positioning and how people think about
their public image in an era of social
media I thank you for this conversation
I really appreciate it thanks appreciate
it for reason TV I'm Tom Crean